all right it's a just barely past 10
o'clock uh and so it's time to convene
the hhs oversight committee
um
uh if if
if i don't look familiar to you it's
because you're usually looking at
chairman mark pearson uh who has gone
down to the cdc to get some direct uh
intel from them i'm not sure what else
he's doing down there but but so mark's
not here i'm going as the vice chair i'm
filling in for him
um from an attendance perspective
um i i see we have five that gives him
us a quorum is that correct mr
so but my clerk
booting up so don't ask me to call the
role
okay um so uh we'll do a roll and i
think that um when we get to um
um senator gray he's he's asked for an
excused absence because he's out in
another legislative meeting taking care
of somebody's budget and i think we can
probably put
representative pearson down also as an
excuse so so would you would you please
call the role
all right
senator gray you said is an excused
absence senator rosenwald here
representative mark pearson you said has
excused absence representative edwards
here
representative soloway here
representative mcmahon
representative nelson
is not here
representative marsh is here that's me
uh representative murphy here
uh senator gaida
is not present
uh so mr chairman we have uh one two
three four five six people present
including the alternates so so that's
six out of nine or six out of ten that
gives you a war okay we do have a quorum
so so representative murphy uh would you
would you um please
have you have you been on oversight this
whole term and i'm just now recognizing
that you're sitting in with us or have
you been recently assigned i have been
recently assigned and thank you for
recognizing me i was asked to join
probably about mid term i'm on
normally i'm on ways and means
um but was asked to
step in as an alternate
i believe about six or seven months ago
late
late part of last year i've been to two
meetings um over the past six months
okay welcome d on a scale of zero to ten
where do you think you are at in terms
of knowing about the department are you
just climbing the learning curve are you
sort of already up there a bit you're
referring to hhs yes
um
i would say that um from my time i'm a
first-time representative and for my
time here
i would say i'm on the learning curve
i'm also on the new hampshire
prescription drug affordability board
but also have practice medicine in the
state for 40 years so i am familiar with
several people
in the hospital association and
in health care in the state itself so
you're a physician i am a physician okay
so the way i run my meetings which is
different than the way
uh
representative pearson does a little bit
is that if you
want to follow up on somebody's comment
just let me know i'm a little hard of
seeing so to let me know
and then i tend to just let you continue
to ask follow-on questions as long as
they are
uh consistent with the questioning that
you're following i i don't make a big
deal of you coming back every time and
asking for a follow-up just as long as
you're keeping a normal dialogue i'm
okay with that but i do reserve the
right to cut you off if i don't think
it's doing i appreciate that i haven't
haven't been in the or for many years
i'm not shy so good good good yeah just
as long as you don't cut on anyone today
all right um
okay so so with that introduction um i
would like
to
um
know
uh if everyone has read the draft
minutes from last meeting
and if so um do you have any changes
that you believe need to be made
mostly to approve minutes that's
submitted
a second first and second um
so
we'll just do a show of hands on this if
you if you're in favor of approving the
draft minutes please raise your hand
opposed or
protocol do i get to vote
as an alternate
well
okay that's i should have done this but
because you're an alternate and because
we're short today you're filling in as
an active
perfect i approve okay so
unanimous
um
okay the next up is we have the uh the
department's commissioner update and
we're treated by deputy commissioner
laurie weaver today and if laura if you
want to excuse me ms weaver if you want
to bring up other people you can do that
now
thank you
good morning
lori weaver hhs deputy commissioner and
i have marissa hen with me uh good
morning marissa hen associate
commissioner
so i'm standing in for the commissioner
today uh for the update we have a a few
things prepared for you
to start out with a brief update on the
hampstead
hospital acquisition and how that's
going um and then there's also some
other inquiries provided by
representative edwards that i'm prepared
to speak to on uh various department
business
mr chair can i get the name of the
second person for the minute
can anyone tell if we're
live on the web
we're good okay thank you i should have
mentioned that this this meeting's being
recorded
so yeah you may want to be careful what
you say or how you say it
thanks
great
good morning um
very pleased to provide an update on
hampstead hospital
how the transition is going and how we
are ensuring
that this facility is is fitting the
needs of new hampshire youth and
families hampstead hospital and
residential treatment facility
and so on that day the state assumed
ownership and we brought in well path
recovery solutions to provide the
clinical operations for the next two
years
uh transition has been remarkably smooth
uh there's really been no disruption to
the high standards of patient care that
we've all come to expect at hampstead
uh recovery solutions is successfully
providing both clinical services and
programming they're also providing a
number of other key
functions across the facility ranging
from housekeeping to building safety
pharmaceutical services etc
staffing capacity and our census has
remained strong
and that has enabled our children's
weightless to remain
quite low as you've probably seen
i think one of the main drivers of
consistency and stability at hampstead
has really been the fact that
the workforce is the same workforce that
has been dedicated to that facility for
so many years
all of those workers were invited to
become
recovery solutions employees and as we
anticipated most of them
accepted that opportunity so the vast
majority stayed at the hospital and then
of course recovery solutions did the due
diligence to ensure that these were the
most qualified and appropriate um
employees to fulfill the hospital's
mission
they also held numerous town halls
one-on-one meetings benefit meetings
just to ensure that all of those
employees felt supported in the
transition
another aspect of stability has been
kathy collins remaining at the helm of
that facility so she was ceo at the time
that the transaction that the purchase
occurred she was also operating as
interim ceo and now kathy is a dhhs
employee serving as ceo of hampstead um
so that has really continued the
continuity that we um that we
prioritized
we are in constant contact with our
federal partners to ensure that all of
the steps around accreditation and
reimbursement remain on track um our
medicaid application has been finalized
and approved
that's for new hampshire we're
continuing to work on other states and
then we are in the process of finalizing
our medicare steps which are important
for continued accreditation
so i just want to talk a little bit
about growth because part of the idea
here is not just that the state is
taking on ownership of this hospital but
that we are growing to fulfill um
greater needs in the community uh
representative edwards uh uh thanks for
letting me interrupt um
i before you get into the growth yeah i
i'd like to establish a baseline of
where we're at because we are
broadcasting and i don't know the number
of citizens that are watching so so if
we could just um have you in 60 seconds
or less
address
what the mission is of this organization
um what the physical capacity is of that
what the staff limited capacity is given
you know that everyone's having a hard
time employing people
what new relationships
needs to be developed for
us to succeed in our mission
and and um
i think i just got cut off as i was
writing my note oh what has you worried
it's a new thing
you're juggling
20 things yeah what are the two or three
things that has you worried yeah and
just if we could get that footprint sure
then we can talk about growth additional
growth sounds like a plan so in short um
well i don't have the mission statement
here in front to paraphrase our mission
is to provide
the highest quality
accessible
cost-effective care to new hampshire
youth and families
that
that we possibly can at this facility in
line with the the department's mission
in line with the state's obligation to
um the communities we serve
in terms of physical capacity there are
it varies day-to-day depending on the
acuity and the emilio makeup of patients
um so there are different
rooming and unit arrangements but
roughly 45 to 55 young people can be
accommodated at any one time and i'll
speak in a minute to some of the
expansion plans
in terms of staffing capacity hampstead
is not immune from the ubiquitous
staffing challenges that we see across
all healthcare facilities in the state
of new hampshire
but what we can say is there has been a
high degree of stability
even though we may have some vacancies
especially when it comes to nursing
especially when it comes to youth
counselors who are sort of those key
personnel who are running the units
we've been able to work with
with recovery solutions to provide an
arrangements including locums per diems
temporary staff to to maintain
short-term stability as we work on
longer-term strategies with them to to
hire and retain a larger workforce so
there's there's really no immediate
urgent concerns it's more about planning
for the long term how to recruit and
retain the highest qualified staff
in terms of new relationships i think
one of the things that's exciting about
this transaction is that it builds on
the work we've been doing for many years
around our children's system of care so
hampstead has been since 2019 when
youth were moved from new hampshire
hospital to hampstead hospital
many new relationships evolved to ensure
that
both when youth come into the facility
as well as when they're discharged warm
handoffs are made with community
partners and with our array of other
continuum services so that that youth
has a really supportive place to land
back in their community with appropriate
care what i think is exciting about this
moment is that we are strengthening all
of those aspects we just met with the
office of the child advocate last week
to ensure that her office is key in
helping us build and establish
all of those continued services to build
out um this system of care
that was a little more than 60 seconds
but
well you did great um and so i don't
know that you hit the uh what has you
worried oh right
and then i thought of another one yeah
as you look at the population outside of
hampstead
maybe you're not calling it a wait list
maybe you just have a list of people
with unmet needs that hampstead would be
the ideal place to put them if you could
give us some idea of how many people
might fit into that that bolus of
patients that we still want to take care
of
so it's very difficult to quantify
demand for services particularly at the
moment we're in in a population health
sense which is that we know
rates of anxiety depression and other
psychological
conditions are on the rise coming out of
the acute phase of the pandemic what is
sometimes hard to predict is when you
expand capacity how much that demand
will will be affected i think one of the
most important and this speaks to the
challenging part of what we are trying
to build at this facility is to
establish
in conjunction with the contractor
recovery solutions the first ever
psychiatric residential treatment
facility in the state of new hampshire
it's hard to
overstate how transformational this
development will be
to date when a young person is not
thriving in any other psychiatric or
residential setting
our only options as a state are to find
placements if we can oftentimes halfway
or across the country
that's really heartbreaking for those of
us in positions where we want to
establish those family family-driven
community-driven sets of services what
the prtf here in new hampshire will
allow is for us to be local here in the
community providing some of these kids
who have experienced the greatest levels
of trauma and behavioral health need
with a place to go in their own backyard
and so i think the prtf is a huge lift
we've set a very bold target of having
this up and running in 180 days we have
nearly daily meetings to work on the
planning and implementation of this but
it's both a challenge and it's going to
fit some of that critical need that
right now we have no other way to meet
um in this state
thank you for that and before you get
into the growth section any committee
members did this stimulate questions
senator roosevelt thank you
um i was going to ask you if willpath
had committed to a date to open the ptrf
but
um
since you said 180 days it doesn't sound
like a commitment but a target
but how many beds
yeah it's 12 bed facility thank you
yeah
and i think that actually oh please
well it's on the same hempstead
we we authorized i think eight or nine
positions financial positions where are
you on filling those
so there were a total of 21
classified positions that include a lot
of finance staff since the state retains
responsibility for
for those finance functions
i believe eight out of the nine are
filled as of now because we primarily
are training on those existing workforce
business office functions that had been
working at hampstead currently
we also have a number of um
non-classified right now unclassified
positions which you may be thinking of
on a management level if you'd like me
to briefly speak to those
yeah sure so that's there are a total of
six positions um at a management level
i've mentioned one of them which is the
ceo kathy collins we've also um are
extending offers this week for highly
qualified individuals for the positions
of
cooclo chief legal officer chief
operating officer
we have extended an offer to a
a real star at hampstead as our chief
compliance officer and we continue to
interview for the positions of um
chief financial officer and contract
manager so we're well on our way to
filling out that
bench of individuals who will be located
on-site
managing
providing the oversight the day-to-day
operational um
uh leadership but they're also dhhs
employees so we're working hand in glove
with them on
on making sure that we're fitting within
state expectations
the chief legal officer
caught my ear and that is i i think the
department has
legal officers and you rely on doj
could you just the the
little snippet
of what justifies um its own dedicated
position over at hampstead yeah so
we felt and in particular melissa saint
cyr our chief legal officer who's wasn't
able to be here today
that there's a key need to have that
level of um
both regulatory oversight to make sure
that we are in compliance with all state
federal laws i mean it's just it's
there's a lot of requirements that we
want to hold hampstead to beyond just
checking the box on their regular um
accreditations we want to make sure that
we're ahead of the game when it comes to
all of that the other piece to remember
is that there are certain situations
where just like with the adult
population we have um
involuntary admissions ieas it's a
little less frequent on the children's
side but it's important that that
process is done especially
thoughtfully
and that requires a a level of um
patient right and representation that
has to happen within the facility within
key time frames and so that the chief
legal officer will play a key role with
those ieas
that's great i'd be tempted to put and
compliance officer in that title but uh
it's just a thought
and uh we threw you off of what you were
planning on i think we've actually
through your questions been able to
honestly touch on um many of the key
points i was going to make around the
prtf and around the management team
um i think i want to you know in terms
of challenges the the workforce
challenges are ones that we are um we
are facing head on and and want to be
really forward thinking about and so i
just want to acknowledge
one of the things that recovery
solutions brings is a national skill set
in reach when it comes to
helping modernize our approaches at
bringing in talented staff including
from out of state and so we are working
with them even this morning we had a
meeting about how we're going to do job
fairs and approach recruitment and
retention in some innovative ways to
make sure that we're drawing upon the
best possible workforce at a challenging
time
um i think other than that we've covered
i wanted to update you on the management
structure which
which we're able to do through the
questions
and um i think the last part that i will
mention is that in addition to a very
comprehensive process of reviewing
quality indicators and reporting
requirements
if you've glanced at the 100
plus page contract a great deal of it is
expectations we have for ensuring
high quality services
we're also trying to be ahead of the
game when it comes to thinking about the
strategy beyond these two years right so
the well path contract is for two years
but our plans and our needs around
hampstead are are
we're really thinking decades into the
future
um in order to undertake a meaningful
procurement process beyond those two
years we have opted to do what's called
an rfi a request for information process
this summer
shortly an rfi will be released and what
that'll allow advocates providers um key
stakeholders to do is to help advise the
department on what we need to be
thinking about strategically as we set
up this procurement for the decades
ahead so you know what are some of the
ways that we need to think about quality
that we need to think about access that
we need to ensure that we're
coordinating with community-based
services and that way we can structure a
contract structure and rfp that really
reflects what the state needs so we're
pretty excited about that process and um
and so you uh the public can expect to
see that rfi released in the next few
weeks and that's i think that covers it
in terms of updates
very nice i um i just want to tell you a
little bit more why i would be tempted
to throw the and compliance into the job
title and
twice i've worked in
legal offices at eastman kodak and
at phillips medical systems and one of
the things that
i learned as a privacy officer
responsible for compliance
was that the legal culture was very much
about waiting for people to bring them
problems and they they were set up as
kind of a billable hours you you bring
to me your issue and i'll i'll work it
out
i think a compliance officer
really needs to be
more proactive and walking around
where the work is getting done and
helping actively educate and i think
that
a good compliance culture is sort of
distinct from a standard legal culture
and
you know anything we can do to just make
sure that everyone realizes that
you know we need we i i think i've heard
you we want to be proactive right and we
do have a cheap compliance officer
position um that has been filled i may
have been remiss and failing to mention
that so there's the chief legal officer
and chief compliance officer recovery
solutions also has a um performance
improvement risk manager positioned um
that will have dotted lines up to the
compliance officer so hopefully that
fulfills what you're talking about and
that's all in the hampstead roster yeah
okay
uh
yes representative mcmahon
i'm having a question uh for specificity
on the starting point of this
uh resource
number one uh indicated with 45 to 55
beds right now
on any given day depending on patient
acuity yes
and okay with that being our benchmark
what is the wait list at this moment
yesterday it was six children on the
wait list it has um in the last few
weeks since the contract took effect it
sometimes gets closer to the 10 mark but
it really hasn't gotten higher than that
which is we are our fingers are crossed
it's obviously affected by seasonal
fluctuations including the end of the
school year and other factors but we are
hopeful that thanks to some of the
staffing models as well as the fact that
the state has helped open one of the
closed units at hampstead hospital that
have been closed throughout the pandemic
that we will continue to see that wait
list eventually reach zero
um one follow-up question
uh then specific to that and this is
looking into the future when the
constant battle is the funding being
there while we're young so that the
service is provided immediately uh do
you see the budget uh be proposed for
the next biennium
being adjusted based on the projected
numbers of
use for the for the new facility as it
now operates
yeah i mean i i think so i think we're
in we're we're monitoring what the
current level of demand is as well as
working um statewide to really see what
are our community mental health center
how do we get ahead so we're not just
waiting for situations to become acute
but what are we seeing we'll probably
hear in a minute about our rapid
response system in terms of um the
crises that are occurring in the
community and what um anticipated uh
impact that we'll have in terms of the
need for that higher level inpatient and
residential care so i think as we head
into the budget season one of the things
that the commissioner and her whole our
whole team are dedicated to is is being
very transparent about the level of need
we have and what the commensurate
funding and resources are that will meet
that need
okay and then one other one one last
point then this is a service for our
whole state
that's right and in fact um one of the
elements of the contract is that it must
prioritize beds for new hampshire youth
before any out of state youth are
considered for inpatient care and then
therefore can there be a reasonable
expectation we do not need to send our
citizens out of state for this service
that's certainly the goal um and and so
far we seem to be um
we seem to be on a successful track
toward that goal um again not only for
that inpatient level of care but also
for those residential levels of care
that we've never previously offered in
the state thank you very much
i i have followed
something you said and represented
mcmahon just exposed it again and that
is uh in the almost two years that i've
been in
deep in this
there there is a continuous
assumption that 100
of all children who are needing services
must stay in this community-based
framework
and that it is always bad to to move a
child out of state to a different
environment
and having once been
a kid and knowing other kids
it just strikes me as a as a layman that
there has got to be a very small group
of kids where it's better for them not
to be around their community friends for
them not to be hanging around the
the bad
examples that they have in life uh and
to get a clean slate where they can get
a fresh start somewhere i'm not asking
you to answer today
but i'd like you to think through this
so because i'd really like to just have
us all in sync
on whether there is ever
the most appropriate care
to find
a change of environment for a kid to
really recover without the weight
of
their uh current community
the freedom from their current community
because some of these are hellholes that
these kids are coming from and i don't
know that it's always good to keep them
in their hellhole but but no answer
today i just i would appreciate a
conversation around that
miss weaver
and miss him
how frequently given where you're at
should we ask you to come back and give
us another update i don't want to like
beat you you need to be doing your own
work but when when might we best have
you back
i would think that quarterly would be
appropriate
okay is mr williams still here
yeah could you could you make a note for
the agenda
thank you sir all right unless you have
something else for us i think uh
ms weaver you're still going to talk to
us about other updates i certainly am
one of the updates that we're going to
talk about is actually in front of you
it's a handout on rapid response at the
request of representative edwards um
i don't know if you want to go over this
at a high level but this is to date
january through april of the data on the
rapid response access point
and i believe this is also posted on a
website
that we can get you that where that is
so that i recognize this uh is this in
response to my questions about where
we're standing with the uh mobile
uh crisis uh response teams correct yeah
okay because we we're now
if i were to look at this and it was
addressing what my questions are it
would say how many of those we have
you know what the utilization per
team is uh you know this this is all
good but it's losing the granularity of
of the response teams
we're happy to provide more information
about the um the individual teams and
and how many responses and their
geographic distribution if you'd like
this is a little bit more high level
showing the the fact that about one in
four of those calls to our centralized
number are resulting in mobile
deployments sure and and we didn't need
this today but we needed to start doing
this because
we're in our next budget cycle
um i think we have currently
six funded mobile response teams is that
is that correct six funded um i'm not
sure i i'm not let's say it's some
number around six um
the division three i know would like to
know
how effective these spends are because
each one of these response teams is
really kind of expensive
you know i think they're what 500 000 a
piece
um
and and that's and that could be a
really great investment but what i'd
like to have us start doing is is making
sure that we're doing a crosswalk
between the deployment of these
uh
teams
what they cost
what value they're adding and and this
is this is good data but in order to
know
next year
should we make it 10 global response
teams and 4 the right number i think
we're going to need slightly different
data right i think it's the right
question to be asking and i think in
terms of return on investment to connect
the two topics of hampstead and how are
we um
how are these investments upstream
preventing that more intensive level of
treatment which very quickly can add up
to um many thousands of dollars for an
impatient stay right and so i think we
need to be thinking holistically about
um
about the preventive opportunity here as
well
all right so we're happy we're happy to
get used it sounds like you'd like more
um granular data on the number of teams
and the um and the way the district the
deployments are distributed across those
geographic regions and teams i i i would
and and i think my my drop dead date is
mid-february
so um are there any other
uh
i don't mean literally drop to it that's
that's the that's the suspense date that
i would like to put on
this
earlier is better are there any uh
questions about the mobile response
teams anyone in the committee
you have
more you want to talk to there's
obviously a lot of data on here did you
want to speak to any of it
no i think we're happy to answer
questions and we'll just note that the
rollout of the federal 988 number
is important in the sense that all of
this work new hampshire has done to
establish its crisis system positions us
for that national roll out in an
important way as we expect
awareness of these crisis resources to
grow substantially
uh representative murphy great thank you
uh just a question you talking about
return on investment and
as chairman asked how many teams do we
need
what are the metrics that you can use or
do you use to
identify the value added with each team
i mean is it the decreased number of you
know suicides or drug overdoses i mean
how do you measure success with these
crisis teams
yeah it's a great question we um we can
certainly there are metrics and we can
get those i don't have them in front of
me they tend to be more process oriented
i think your question is an interesting
one which is how do we look at some of
those
those larger population health outcomes
suicide in particular is going to be
very difficult to measure because while
it's still far too
common a
a cause of death it is also fortunately
a fairly rare and so the n is too small
to really often see measurable
difference through a single intervention
but i think it's it's um it's incumbent
on us to be thinking through how we are
measuring progress and how we are course
correcting when we aren't um
achieving that so happy to follow up
with some of the process indicators as
well as the ways that we're linking this
to our larger 10-year mental health plan
and our statewide suicide prevention
plan
it might my follow-up to that is really
in healthcare it's been often times very
difficult to measure success i mean
we've seen that for decades and so i
appreciate the difficulty you may have
in doing that
but it's still something that we strive
to do anyway um
so thank you thank you
so thank you uh representative murphy um
because i realize that when i talk about
value-added people don't group they may
assume that since i have primarily a
financial background i'm just worried
about dollars i'm not i i'm looking for
the type of metrics that you just
mentioned how are we being uh clinically
efficacious in this and then how how are
we keeping track of that that's that's a
part of the value added knowing what the
dollars and cents are and we have to
know that but but
i'm really looking for the the larger
uh
concept of value add
one one more comment on that with the
with the rfi even for hampstead that's
what we also need the community and in
particular the medical community to help
us think about how do we measure even
the efficacy of a hospital is it
readmissions is it the number of
re-engagements back in the community
with a therapist or provider so i think
these are the questions we're wrestling
with not as a sort of intellectual
exercise but to get us to some concrete
measures that allow us to invest
resources the right place
in relative to representative edwards
you know previous mention about you know
finance it would like to know how this
is you know worked
you know we all also recognize that
investment today does not yield a result
a year from now or in the biennium that
we're talking about so it's very hard to
understand that and i appreciate that so
i appreciate your work and efforts in
doing that thank you
so since this is your your first term
and and because there's an ongoing
discussion about the role of finance uh
after the role of the policy committee
what what i've worked out with
representative pearson is
that the division iii finance team isn't
just looking at the dollars and cents do
we have the money
of course we have to answer that but i i
think uh one of our we have a broader
fiduciary responsibility to just make
sure that
we understand whether or not uh the
money that we're investing is uh
effective if it's efficient uh you know
we're looking at the the programmatics
as as well and not just you know the
naked dollars
okay continuing on with a couple of the
other updates that representative
edwards had asked about was our first
was our fte uh status in terms of how we
reached our have we gone over our cap of
three thousand uh to date as of this
week
out of about 3200 positions we only have
uh
2563 of them filled which is about a 20
vacancy rate which is what we've been
operating on for quite some time and i
will be honest it's quite challenging so
if we can think about all of the
programs that we have and the
responsibilities and the services that
we're required to run um finding the
staff is uh no not unique to hhs but
definitely is a pain point for us for
sure
so so i have a question for that um this
was my first year in finance and um i
won't i'll admit that i didn't know
everything i was doing but uh would you
is it is it correct that the
400 or 500 vacancies that you have that
the the savings on that personnel cost
that we did put in the budget that that
money is going to make up a
good portion of the 50 million dollar
laps that i think we also obligated you
to
correct it is i think it equates to this
fiscal year i think it's about 20
million for personnel lapse for this
fiscal year and then next year similar
so
that's a high lapse in personnel for us
but yes that's we've had to give up that
money and we'll give it up again for
fy23
any other questions before i move to the
next item
i i believe you had asked about
sysc and spu as well
so sysc i think where the legislation
has landed with a closure date of
march of 23 is definitely challenging
for the department i don't think we
quite have a
a plan yet on what's going to happen
with that but we are obligated to move
forward with a design we've been working
on a design for well over a year we
spent all of last summer and fall coming
up with that design with stakeholders
internal external
nationally i had a consultant work with
us so we're moving forward to procure an
architect somebody to help us with that
design would look like
and right now we're in the process of
trying to get that submitted through the
proper channels so
uh so so let me give you a legislative
update on that
i've been talking to
senator daniels and a few other people
to say okay we officially have no plan
the legislature didn't help you um and
so because a judge could look at this 31
march
closure date as a as you have to evict
everyone on the 1st of april if if
unless the legislature gives you other
authority
the simple thing that we think we're
going to try to rush through
at the beginning and next term
is
at least a one-year extension
so that we don't run into a
judicial order to empty the facility
that would definitely be uh
helpful to us reaching the goal of
having a different facility in a
different location okay now
we don't have to submit to drafting
until i don't know september i think so
if you could just think about
how much time is the right amount of
time
knowing that it would be
easy to say well let's make it three
years
but
the legislature is would probably not
accept that because there's always this
paranoia that you guys aren't really
wanting to close it and i i can't
explain why that is but
it is kind of the
boundary condition that people want to
keep it shorter if they can to make sure
that we're still moving forward
aggressively sure i understand that i
will say that the department is fully
committed to creating a facility that
meets the needs of that population and
that is different from how it stands
today which is why we're moving forward
with our design because we believe we
have what that model is and what it
should look like so thank you great
thank you
the other thing you asked about was the
psychiatric forensic hospital
i would like to give you an update brief
update that
project is on target we are working with
smrt which is an architect firm
we actually have another public
information session next thursday night
june 30th at six o'clock we've held
about three of these already
open to anyone that wants to attend in
particular the abutters on the property
of sap's campus
as well we have the
city assistant city manager as part of
our
steering committee for that design
as well as other folks in nami is also a
partner with us in that project so we
are on track
we are looking to procure a contractor
for to start the build uh this fall and
then anticipating that construction
would start in early 23
and be completed by 24.
so if you are interested in looking at
those designs the plans any of the
minute meetings on the department's
website we have all of that information
so at this point without giving any
procurement or other business sensitive
information away
what's your sense of the likelihood that
the new facility will be in concord
the new facility will be in concord it
will be
attached to new hampshire hospital
so it it is that part has been
determined so they are the design is
actually an addition to and taking up
one of the parking lots at new hampshire
hospital so although we'll have one
entrance it will be two separate
uh facilities once you get inside so i
understand that and that and i think
that's probably a good decision i'm just
curious when was that decision finalized
says it been months weeks
uh it's been months i think before we
procured the architect
we had that decision
made i think it was
what are we in june last year i believe
okay
i know for sunday new center obviously
we don't have a location that is to be
determined okay thank you i i had missed
that decision so thank you
sure
um if you leave for my updates that's
what i had for you today
okay that's great does anyone have
anything random for the go ahead uh
senator
thank you um
the dental bill hasn't been signed yet
but it will be
and i'm wondering if on the next
few meetings we because the timing is so
tight
um in order
to have the benefit
in place by next spring whether we can
ask the department to just update us
regularly on
the waiver and the state plan amendments
and
i i think that's a great great ask and i
already saw mr williams saying yes and
he's sort of the keeper of the agenda so
the odds just went up
anything else
um it's jim
representative mcmahon to follow up on
on the senator's question there um
can with the guidance of our
commissioner and ms han
what is the
uh
oversight that's required to stay front
and center with the with the authorities
having jurisdiction in washington that
this plan will be approved
the dental plan that's correct yes yes
um i'd have to get back to you on that i
don't have that
answer and and i said in the context and
just what i've learned over 20 years
that there's a benign harassment you
have to put in function to do this with
manners of course uh but it's this is
something from the legislative side that
we could assist with
in in that regard and so it's
and just as a chair it's indicated you
have
multiple silos that you you both your
professionals are dealing with is that i
would like to be one of those people you
can call on to follow up and and work
with the senator to ensure that this
happens
so that the the faceless bureaucrats
which we'll know i'll never see but i'm
making these decisions uh that we're
front and center and then we have our
next meeting we have an up to date
saying something is actually happening
versus we're still waiting for something
to happen
so i wanted to see what you got
specifically my question is what can we
do to assist in that regard thank you i
will we will let you know absolutely and
if you put a timeline on that when will
you let me know
my next meeting
i can let you know sooner it's up to you
uh sooner is always better so i can be
intellectually prepared to yeah yeah the
next meeting we haven't talked about it
yet but it's looking like 23 september
which would be beyond our ols drop date
i think so
i think if we're going to do anything to
help in legislation we need to know
sooner but sure within the next week or
so does that work for you
tomorrow would work yeah yeah but oh
really yeah i think that the individual
i need to connect with is on vacation so
i just uh
so if that individual's doctor sarah
finney let me just say what she's been
briefing us on representative mcmahon
yes sir um
so she's known that this program will
require two waivers
and she says that she's uh has actively
engaged the folks at cms
and that they understand the waivers and
and everything that they've said has
been a positive that they will approve
the waivers but saying you'll approve
the waiver and having a
waiver approval is two different things
so so your your question is is is
very relevant um but the um there's
reason for optimism
good and appreciate that additional
information for that optimism just to
show that we're on the same page with
you
and if there's something further that
can be done i
just like to offer that
offer as much as i can to be there for
you thank you thank you very much
okay uh are there any other community
questions or
mountain commissioner you got anything
else you want to tell us why you're
while you're here i think we've taken up
a lot of time already i thank you for
the time to give all the updates i think
it's been very valuable i know i've
found it useful
so so thank you um next up we'll have
a discussion on hb 1290 establishing a
task force on precision medicine i
believe this is representative jeffrey
salloway who's going to walk us through
are you going to sit up front or sit
there it's up to you so
thank you mr chairman
um
i'll uh
speak without a microphone
it has my attention that with the advent
electronic
transmissions of documents that the
volume of waste paper coming out of this
building is flying and therefore in the
attempted solution
i am uh handing out a 13 page document
which
which describes the progress of the
temporary
subcommittee on precision medicine
thank you
um for those of you who are bothered by
insomnia i have a
copy
if you uh
look at it late in the evening
about
night you won't get past page five and
your problem will be solved
so
this is i hope the final report
of the
interim
task force on precision medicine
those of you who have watched the
process of this
effort
know that it is a memorial uh to
representative kathy rogers whom we lost
this last year it is based on uh her
submitted bill hb 1290 calling for
legislative action in the area of what
is known as precision medicine what you
uh have in this document
in the uh first four pages is uh what
our serving chairman has called
the corporals report
that's the
summary uh four-page summary of
the efforts of the interim task force
and following that
from pages 5 through 11
are the generals report
and this is the appendix with all of the
details
that get fairly technical
beginning on page 11
is
the most recent statement of pages 11-13
and these are the transition documents
to move this effort from
the interim task force to a standing
subcommittee
of a
health and human services oversight
basically i was asked to uh prepare
uh some contacts and some directives
based on the charge to the committee
um
and that's
here in this transition document
beginning on page 11. again uh it is for
those of you who suffer from insomnia
uh i need to point out
uh just a couple of
minor points and then i'll be done
please understand that
i have had a bias in preparing this
document
the
bias is that it is pitched
particular toward oncology it's pitched
toward cancer
i believe that people in search of
precision medicine solutions
most often most
frequently are people who are dealing
with issues of cancer
and as a result this is an effort to put
the standing
subcommittee in contact with people who
can speak authoritatively
to the issue of cancer
mr rollo that is
for the benefit of the new hampshire
cancer society
the people that i've recruited are top
flight researchers they are clinicians
uh a caveat that
the idea of including oncologists
included with clinical expertise is not
to
give us direction in terms of policy
decisions it's to orient the standing
committee to what the issues are that
patients face
in looking for precision medicine
solutions to diagnosis of cancer
i apologize for that bias
the other comment that i wish to make is
that there is uh
toward the end of this document
um pages
it's really on page 13.
there is a last statement on creating
and maintaining quality services
and
i will speak as cautiously as i can for
the record
in my own
communication with
oncologists in particular
it has come to my attention that there
are numbers of entrepreneurial
organizations that are moving into the
area
of precision medicine what we can call
generally precision medicine
and they are offering patients
new means of diagnosis and therapy
traditional oncologists occasionally
have doubts about the efficacy of these
organizations but point out that they
can be highly profitable
and as a result they become a magnet
for entrepreneurship often with funding
that comes from
uh sources that are less than
normal uh they often involve foreign
investment
uh often involve uh investment by people
who are much more interested in
profitability rather than quality
assurance
so as a result of that um i did do some
research i was able to identify
someone who has worked with such an
organization in new hampshire who no
longer works for that organization
and who doesn't wish at this point to be
identified
inasmuch as that person has become a
whistleblower
indicating that
the financial
manipulations of that organization are
subject to
federal inquiry so
as the task force gets appointed and as
they are looking for information in that
particular area of quality assurance
i may be able to
recruit the
former cfo of that organization to come
forward and speak for the record at the
moment i regret that i cannot provide a
name
so
mr chairman
i thank you if there are questions i
would be very glad to respond yeah i i
have i have a question or two um
first you know thank you i i know that
this has been a labor of love for you
you put a lot of work into it you you've
properly honored uh
the honorable kathy
rogers and i'm really glad that uh that
we've done that
um and we'll continue to do that
my my question
is as i'm looking at this transition to
a standing task force is it your
expectation that we establish one
through rsa or as i understand it we
have used the oversight committee to
get an interim
canoe into the water so we could at
least start going somewhere do you do do
you see this as continuing as an
extension of the oversight committee or
do you see this as a legislative
committee i i must say mr chairman i
think that the oversight committee
operates with such a high level of
insight and professionalism
and
with all due respect to the house of
representatives
our processes in the house are slow
ponderous
and i think this is an area in which i
would prefer to see us move uh quickly
and i believe that the oversight
committee is probably the best organ for
the house to do that
thank you for that and i my next
question is as i'm looking at the
types of skill sets that you're
populating this with or recommending
population i don't see a retired public
health professor from unh i can't think
of a single one
if you could help us find a unh
professor who's familiar with the
subject that would be great to have that
person
continue to be involved
thank you mr chairman i think i thank
you okay
all right
are there any
questions for
professor representative salloway
all right thank you well thank you
which moves us to
patricia
tricia tilly
do you want to come up patricia
mrs tilly
you'll always be miss tilly to me
now now what i i think you're going to
talk about is this um
ongoing effort with a relatively new
twist on it on helping
provide
a better access to clinical and mental
health services
inside the walls of
select schools that is correct thank you
representative good morning members of
the committee
so
thank you for the opportunity to give a
brief update on where we are in
providing some school-based health
services in the upcoming year i'm going
to preface and i'll probably say it a
couple more times we are in active
recruit active procurement currently so
i can talk
in a wide way around what our requests
for applications were how we got this
money into the state but i can't really
talk about exactly what's going to
happen because that's currently in
negotiation so just with that preference
i think we can start back
in january even last fall where public
health was fortunate enough to receive
several blocks of money for covid19
response in one of those funding sources
called our workforce funding sources
very long name but we've sort of
shortened it to workforce
there was an opportunity within there to
provide a certain percentage of those
funds to support school age health
programs or school-based health programs
programs for school-aged kids so in
january we brought forth a fiscal item
to fiscal
it was number
22016. if you want to google that
and that authorized us to accept these
new
cdc funds
to to provide a whole host of activities
um support workforce in our communities
in our local two city health departments
in our public health networks
we we have some community health workers
are out in the field funded with those
funds and in that also was the
opportunity to support school-based
health and that was articulated in the
fiscal letter
back in january
so
fast forward to april 2022
we put forward a request for
applications
to provide school-based health services
in communities it's important to note
that those requests for applications
were limited to our existing um
federally qualified health centers and
community health centers that currently
have a contract with the with the
department so we as many of you know we
have a network of community health
centers in the in the community we
provide funding for those um health
centers in addition to their medicaid
and all of the other federal sources
they get public health also provides uh
funding for those um
those facilities to do work that is you
know funded that is not typically funded
by medicaid to do a lot of the
engagement work some of the
transportation and really sort of the
glue around those medicaid billable
services one of the things that our
community health centers have always
done is had partnerships with schools
and so
to some degree differently in each
community they have worked with their
schools to ensure that referrals get
where they need to be that kids have
access to medicaid or commercial health
insurance
and also to in some cases to provide
support to the school nurses so what
this rfa did is it provided an
opportunity for additional federal funds
for them to do a much more intentional
and and robust um partnership to provide
both physical health services things
like
physical exams sports exams
acute care if needed or desired
as well as behavioral health services
including anxiety and depression
screenings
other sort of
primary care type services counseling
services and crisis intervention all of
those are things that were in the scope
of services that health centers could
respond to if that was something that
they would be interested in doing and
that they had a relationship with a
school to do that with so we are in that
procurement process now i can tell you
we've received
applicants we are going through the
negotiations at this time it's important
to note that um the selected applicants
uh needed to acknowledge that they had
to have parental permission of course or
caregiver permission before any services
were ever rendered to any uh student or
youth um that goes without saying but it
was said within the context of our
contract what we will do as part of our
monitoring process we will approve
all of the policies around how they will
engage and get parental permission
before treating any student
we will monitor we will approve that
policy once um once the contract is put
in place and then what we will also do
as part of our monitoring is we will go
and do probably an audit a very you know
an audit with a lower case a audit
through a site visit as we do check
other as we always check if they're in
compliance with our scope of services so
we will do that once the project is up
and running we're very excited about
this opportunity to provide a little bit
more resources to schools i think all of
us have acknowledged and seen the need
for
both physical health and behavioral
health services in this population
we know that several many parents are
interested in ensuring that their kids
can get care at school it is far more
convenient you don't have loss of school
time in the same way i mean i can
remember as a kid being thrilled when
you had a doctor's appointment because
you basically got the day off and maybe
some ice cream
this you know allows
a much more convenient opportunity for
parents to make sure that there's
consistent care for their kids
folks don't have to take time off of
work again it is all voluntary it is all
in with parental permission um but we're
there really to be a resourceful to the
families and quite frankly to the school
nurse and and the administration who
have really um acknowledged that they
need those sorts of support so i'm happy
to answer any questions right now again
very big picture a little bit vague
uh so thank you for that and i i want to
thank you it's been what three or four
weeks since you allowed me in your
office to talk about some of this so i i
appreciate your transparency hey um
so on the
notion of parental approval
i i believe what you're saying is that
the parents will opt in
before the very first exam takes place
correct
okay will that opt-in
be
case-based or will it be episodic
and and because i'm probably making
terms up here
case-based to me is a
kid has a condition
parents say go ahead and treat that
condition and if it's three or four or
five meetings it's it's all covered
under that one opt in
versus episodic
each instance before the the patient the
student is seen
is that going to trigger its own opt-in
so thank you for that question so this
is where we're really going to need to
look to the policy of the healthcare
provider you know they have the
experience in how to provide ensure that
there is um parental permission
much in the way that if you sent your
high school student right now to the
doctor's office you know how how would
they ensure that they have parental
permission for that so i'm going to
hedge a little bit and say we will look
to the policy of the health care
provider who will be doing that
and approve that policy ensure that it
makes sense for that um
for within the context of that school
uh so so thank you for that and you know
from our other conversation that my
concern is there's uh this group of
agitated involved citizens that are
worried about the relationship with
government uh and particularly when it
comes to schools and mental health of
their kids and i just think that uh
an easier way to sell this to the entire
state of new hampshire is if we had an
episodic
opt-in
uh and i would uh and i would suggest
because you know let me you know maybe
that won't always be the case but uh
like a two-year
phase out do episodic for two years and
then you know transition to case base if
if necessary it's
again i'm just brainstorming and it's up
to you guys to run the program i'm i'm
just telling you what it's easier to
sell thank you all right
yes
senator roosevelt thank you
so if a
student
is
experiencing a mental health crisis
yes suicidal or something
there would still be a need to get
parental permission first
yeah that that'd be a different we're
calling the crisis right so thank you
thank you for that question senator so
this is where i'd want to really go to
the policies of the health care provider
to see what and what how they will
inform families ahead of time we
certainly um know right now you know if
you think about it the school nurse you
know the school nurse often calls
parents and says can i give your child a
tylenol i would anticipate something
like that if there were not already if
that child would not already receiving
ongoing treatment whether counseling or
other services
that the school nurse or the healthcare
provider would pick up the phone and
ensure that the parent was aware of the
services their child was
receiving i i i think i agree with your
premise there as i understand it senator
is that if it's a
emergent care if it's a suicide attempt
uh you know
it's like any healthcare emergency you
gotta
act but but still you have to inform so
that'll be interesting how they take
care of that
um i have two other questions i don't
know if we rehearse these
um
one is
i think we'd like to be able to talk
about how this program will affect
school-based property taxes
with the additional care some of that
care may be reimbursable by medicaid and
other insurance carriers
where where will that revenue go will it
stay strictly within the healthcare
provider that we're contracting with or
will there be some payout to
the schools
so that they may mitigate some of their
school taxes you know i think this is
part of the relationship we're asking
those health care providers to develop a
relationship with their schools we will
not dictate that you know i think it is
appropriate to consider that if a
healthcare provider is providing a
service they will be able to re get
reimbursement for that through
commercial or um
or public insured through medicaid that
i think that is appropriate um but the
healthcare part the healthcare center
and the school are going to negotiate
their relationship these funds is really
just get the program up and running
really the glue to stick that together
whether you need an exam table in a
particular room or just even the
outreach that's going to be involved
with that we know that there are a lot
of startup costs and that's what these
funds will will fund
okay so my next question it's a hot
topic uh in the news and and that is uh
the senate apparently uh passed some
type of red flags legislation in their
bill yesterday i i don't know what's in
there i don't know the extent it's going
to be mandatory in new hampshire um but
um but what i am curious about is
assuming that that there is no red flag
law a new hampshire-based one or a
us-based one
if a mental health provider is
counseling a student and perceives that
that student
is a threat to others i mean obviously
we're worried about suicide threat to
self but but if uh if there's a
perception that that student is a is a
threat to others
or there already existing laws that
would allow that mental health provider
to
flag that student to say that we have a
potential risk and we need additional
services here
um thank you for that question and i
must admit that that's about 10 feet
outside of my uh my expertise but what i
can say is that certainly existing ferpa
laws we know that there are privacy laws
within schools that need to be abided by
as well as our any mental health
practitioner is going to work within
their licensure and within their um
ethics and the policies of their health
care
system so you know i anticipate they
will work fully within the context of of
whatever laws are on the books today or
tomorrow
so i'm going to offer what
representative mcmahon offered earlier
as a as a guy who fed my family with
privacy law issues i i'm interested in
the privacy aspect of this but
but if um if as if you had
in parallel
uh
a conduct of
kind of a legal inquiry into what a red
flag like
notification
would look like and what sort of
legislative changes
might be needed
i would consider
sponsoring something like that and with
this
september ols date thank you okay and
maybe mr williams will help he knows a
little so all right thank you
are there other questions from miss
tilly
outstanding thank you have a great week
just before you go it it's my
understanding that existing law would
allow
any provider in the school in fact would
require any provider in the school
to uh seek uh uh
intervention on behalf of somebody who's
a threat to others including uh
involuntary emergency hospitalization am
i correct about that thank you thank you
thank you so
so i like the answer you gave
representative marsh i was trying to
look for the same answer how
what what why did you answer him and not
me
um because i didn't want to misspeak to
some of those parameters right there but
i believe that we are in line with what
um representative marsh noted
okay that's great um all right thank you
thank you
i think she just likes you more bill
i i think it had to do with the
specificity of my question okay thank
you thank you all right
uh okay so next up uh we have someone
sitting in for melissa hardy who i
understand is
is ill or otherwise occupied we're going
to talk about long-term care supports
come on up
and say your name for the record
hi my name is sandy farrows i'm the
bureau chief at the bureau of
developmental services and i'm here
today to provide the committee with an
update on the developmental disabilities
and acquired brain disorder wait list
good morning chris santaniello associate
commissioner in here for melissa hardy
so we'll get started for those of you
that may not be familiar with the dd and
the abd waivers these waivers are 1915 c
waivers that allow us to provide
supports to individuals in the community
and we call them a waiver because it is
a service that is an alternative to an
institutional
care so we are waiving institutional
care for home and community-based
services i'm going to start with an
update on our dd waiver
and our data is as of april 13th we do
these reports quarterly and we did not
have our report last month because the
committee accommodated my being out so
thank you for doing that
so as of april 13th we had 723
individuals that were funded on the
waiver through quarters one through four
and our
the people that are funded are broken
down by different categories and
category a are people that
are exiting the school district
and receiving adult services category b
are people that are new to our services
and c are people that are currently
receiving services but
accessing new services so out of those
723 people
we had the majority of them
were people receiving services currently
the c category 64
we had 31 a's
and five percent b's
so that's the developmental disabilities
waiver
i'm moving over to the in-home support
waiver next which is children with
developmental disabilities and as of
april 13th
we had funded 58 people
through quarters one through four
and
eighty-nine percent were new to services
and eleven percent received enhanced
services
and for the acquired brain disorder
weaver as of april 13th we had 33 people
that were funded through quarters one
through four
and six of those folks were new to
services and 27 of them
were going to receive enhanced services
so those were all funded through the
four quarters and again that was as of
april 13th we're very close to the end
of the fiscal year so in our next report
we'll be able to give a full annual
report
and that's my update any questions i i
have a brainstorm for you this this may
be ridiculous and you're you're allowed
to tell me that
um i i
if you were here earlier you maybe
picked up on the idea that the mobile
response teams
uh are of interest
and i know that they have some staffing
if it happens that we were to look at
the data of a mobile response team and
found that it's
appears underutilized to the
professionals
is it possible that they could be used
to supplement
some of the
dd services that that
that you're trying to get provided or is
the skill mix and the mobile response
team so fundamentally different that's a
just a non-starter
i don't i mean i i would have to look at
the function of the mobile response team
and see exactly what they're responding
to so if it's a crisis situation i think
anyone anybody anybody would benefit
from
services provided from an emergency
response team if they're in crisis but
we also have to look at the population
and how we would fund it and chris can
probably wait sure thank you for thank
you for that question um and so
really what the services sandy's talking
about are day services some residential
supports services to
help somebody work
participate in community activities so
the skill set would be different if
somebody was also receiving
developmental services and mental health
services and were in need of crisis
response that they would partner in that
way but i wouldn't
switch it up that way
representative murphy
thank you and thank you
update my question is i'm assuming that
it may be wrongly so that the acquired
uh disorders are more of the
older population that you serve
and as opposed to those that are
required in youth in my question is
for these people at home and for their
services how
long do you help them i mean to what age
group i mean is this go on and on and on
or
what is the age span in which you take
care of the acquired uh
disorders
well thank you for that question um we
so this is long-term supports and
services so we serve people all the way
through death
and your point about acquired
disabilities is a good point because it
really distinguishes which population
people fall into
so if you have a brain injury under the
age of 22 it affects your developmental
process and so that's considered a
developmental disability
if you have a brain injury at the age of
30 however it's considered an acquired
brain disorder so those are two
different populations with two different
approaches to treatment
so if i may fall
i was once involved in a lot of trauma
and so i saw a lot of kids but also
adults involved in motor vehicle
accidents whatever
and so i wasn't aware that there was an
age distinction between
the the services option other different
services for those acquired at age say
20 in a motorcycle versus somebody
that's you know
30 on a roof and falls off you know it
what are the differences in services i'm
just trying to understand what you think
the services range in in intensity so
there are people that need very minimal
services they might need a couple of
hours a week for support in their home
and there are people that may need
24-hour care because they have total
care needs so what we do is we look at
the individual needs and then
build services around them and we have
providers in the community that do that
and we have 10 area agencies that also
um are responsible for services in their
regions
and just a quick follow-up do you have
on your staff these providers or do you
contract with say physical therapy
occupational therapists you know rehab
specialists you know are these on your
staff or these people you contract
directly with typically their contract
thank you you're welcome thank you
oh yes thank you mr chairman
we're very close to the end of the
fiscal year
do you know
or can you get back to us with
how much of your appropriation for these
waiver programs
has been spent um
to provide services and
if there's
money left over does it last now or stay
in the program and lapse next year or
never lapse
so the money will carry over if there's
unspent money
forever it does not lapse ever yes it
will move into the next year and we we
can get you that information as well
do you know one hand not often today no
sorry thank you
so so i think that the specific question
is at the end of this two-year budget
year do your monies lapse and that would
have been put into the budget whether
they lapsed or not so you're you
specifically know these are non-lapsing
funds all right thank you
jim
uh yes
yes
i'm madam if i may uh just a
clarification
uh for myself is um
since we have zero just looking at the
list that was provided to us says zero
on the wait list
in in uh going for uh going forward
is there a rate of pay adjustment on the
plan to encourage and ensure that
the needs of new hampshire are met
by the staff required for in-home care
a rate of play pay attention yeah yeah
i'll clarify that that was an issue over
the last number of years um richard pay
and then uh
people just weren't staying with the job
so if they came on they didn't last long
because of just the uh the pay would say
because like 15 and then was uh
negotiating with the kremlin to give it
to anything worthwhile
and to keep them and uh
that being said is what is
part of your
prognostications for the future planning
with the but with the budget to come
relative to the uh rate of pay to
to um when you advertise for more more
folks that will need to meet the the
waitlist requirements not talking about
the expertise within that individual but
it's just to have people available that
will
will want to take these jobs because
they can make a living doing it yes so
as as with all of our
service delivery systems across the
state we are experiencing a significant
workforce shortage that was only
exasperated by the pandemic
and we are currently as a system looking
at our rate methodology to um really
take advantage of the opportunity to
build into our rate methodology some
incentive incentivization for providers
around building workforce
capacity and
and really incentivizing those providers
to have some kind of a credentialing
option for direct support professionals
in our system
so there is oh i'm sorry oh no go ahead
is that still truly the 10 area agencies
so the yes the 10 area agencies are the
server they are responsible for services
within their regions and what we're
looking at as a system is a rate
methodology to determine rates for
individuals based on those individuals
needs so the hope is that that approach
to rate development will be consistent
across our state which would be the ten
area agencies as well
okay all right thank you
okay this is a faulty memory question i
i think the legislature in the last
couple of months tried to fix
the
five percent commitment that we had made
in the budget to up
contract
values by five percent in the hopes that
the
the the contractors would pass that
money on to the workforce and and like i
said this is probably a memory problem
go ahead no it's not it's not a memory
problem so what we had is we had the
home and community-based fmap dollars
and i think that's what you're referring
to because we brought that to fiscal
and so that is one-time money that was
passed on to the provider agencies
and it's really meant to enhance their
workforce the challenge with that from a
provider's perspective is it's one-time
money right and so a provider can't
increase somebody's rate of pay unless
they know they have a way to continue
that rate of pay um so
it's it's helping a little bit with
recruitment and retention but we really
do need to look at the rates long term
it's helping with recruiting and
retention because i assume that they're
turning those monies into bonuses
potentially that's what they could be
doing correct
senator roosevelt thank you i i believe
you're thinking of the nursing home rate
increase bill
where we we did account for our
budget
miscalculation and the governor has
signed that bill okay well thank you for
that uh i i know that when we first in
the budget cycle started to put a 5 in
for a targeted
medical service that that opened the
doors and everyone wanted the same five
percent we ended up giving that five
percent out a lot so
uh more than the initial target and and
so i just was curious
and and that's all right um
that's i i don't need people to fix my
memory too much but we did have 6.2
percent of medicaid provider rate
increases
that went into effect in
this is why you're the senator and i'm
still just a representative i think
um okay so um
on the graph
i i i just i'm looking for a key
that tells me what black means and what
blue means
black is quarterly
quarters right um i have to
sorry i
believe that black is quarterly
reporters i believe it now that you've
said that
okay and then
i think the first time we had this
conversation was maybe eight or nine
months ago where
the aha moment was that you guys can
dole out
or appropriate or or encumber
the money
so that we're reporting a zero wait list
but there's still the reality
that there are
patients needing care that aren't
getting care because that money hasn't
worked its way all the way through the
system to where
the people are providing the care
are actually acting and getting the
numbers down is is is that still true
and is that not on this graph right
that's true and so we have been tracking
those numbers and what we've heard from
agencies mainly is that the challenge
with getting services started which is
about 28
right now for the dd waiver
in terms of people that have received
services but have not yet or excuse me
receive funding but have not yet
received services 28
the challenge is finding a provider
agency to do it and even if they have a
provider agency finding staff within
that organization to do it it's the
workforce shortage that is the challenge
okay so
that to me that's good oversight
information and i'm happy to see zero
wait lists but i i think i think what we
really want to know is
what impact are we having on patient on
patients lives and so if we could figure
out a way to graphically represent this
other
yet to be served population i i i know
personally i'd like to be able to see
that as well suspect representative
mcmahon would i know senator rosenwald
loves data
representative salloway
thank you mr chairman this is a
follow-up to your comments so looking at
the data
okay as you have it um
this is what we would call a double hump
distribution in statistics
and and statisticians see this all the
time and what this
commonly represents is
a hidden need
uh that just hasn't hit the record
keeping yet
so um my question is if you take a look
at the double hump
are we now going to see a rise again
and are we going to need policy changes
to deal with it is that going to go up
again
so the humps that you reference here are
years that we did not receive enough
waiting list funding
um um in in our budget proposals and the
last
since about
2016 on the waitlist has been fully
funded so that's why the numbers have
gone down so the
developmental services is contingent on
on the funding um through the waitlist
but also now that we're able to carry
dollars forward that does help with that
okay any other questions for
our good folks
all right um
well thank you thank you for coming by
have a great weekend i hope you have
great plans
and now we're ready for mr holt to come
give us our regular annual data report
on the therapeutic candidates program
is this is the state of our nation
our program
good
or do we have problems so you see storms
on the horizon
thank you mr chair members of the
committee the state of the therapeutic
cannabis program is good solid um their
the legalization bill this year did not
pass um so uh that that potential
doesn't threaten the uh you know the
program um for at least another year um
we'll revisit that next year depending
on what legislation comes through
next year
for the record my name is michael holt
i'm a section administrator for the
division of public health services i
oversee both the therapeutic cannabis
program and the prescription drug
monitoring program i'll be providing
summary
information for the two annual reports
for those two programs
so for the therapeutic cannabis program
the report is required by
rsa 126x10 it's also reported to the
board of nursing and the board of
medicine
and the report contains information from
three categories
the department's own therapeutic
cannabis registry
the annual reports that are submitted by
the alternative treatment centers in the
state
and an annual patient satisfaction
survey
so the report provides information about
qualifying patients
designated caregivers and certifying
medical providers who are active in the
program as of june 30th 2021.
yes this is we're coming to you late
with this data
so the report highlights so the program
continues to experience growth um the
the program's seen steady growth over
its six years of existence uh and as of
last june the program had
237 registered qualifying patients
currently a year later
there are about 13
500 patients so still in this past year
we've seen program growth
the majority of patients are in their
50s and 60s
however we do have a very small number
of miners who are on the program as well
and as of the report date there were six
minors on on the program
uh
in terms of the qualifying medical
conditions that
that one must have in order to be
eligible for the program again the vast
majority of patients more than 70
percent of patients on the program are
certified by their providers uh for
specific pain conditions either chronic
pain acute pain or spinal cord injury
disease
pain the other most frequent conditions
that we see are ptsd about 18 of the
population
and cancer at about 6.5 percent of the
there are almost
1300 participating medical providers who
have certified at least one patient for
the program
um that number continues to increase as
well providing greater access to uh to
the to the to the program for patients
76 percent are physicians 28 are aprns
can i ask you a question there
just to pinpoint on that
when i first became aware of this five
years ago or so there was active concern
amongst those with medical licenses that
they were under threat from the federal
government to have their medical
licenses pulled if they got too involved
in this program
that's the way i remember it
but in five years
what do you think the attitude has
become of the physicians involved in
this program
well certainly in new hampshire there's
been no federal action taken against any
new hampshire licensed physician aprn or
pa
in this regard
there is stigma still associated with
the program
many providers
simply
won't certify their patients even if
they have a qualifying medical condition
the barrier to entry for
for uh providers is is minimal um
in that there's no registration
requirements there's no continuing
medical education requirements uh there
is no list right of of certifying
providers in the state um if you're
lucky enough as a patient to
have a have a have an existing
relationship with a provider who's
willing to certify you you're you're in
good shape but we see
uh we hear regularly from patients it's
the it's
it's the most common
call or question that we get of
my doctor won't certify me
what do i do
um and so you're absolutely right that
stigma still remains amongst the
uh the the
provider community about entering this
area um this alternative therapy um
their reasons aren't illegitimate i mean
there's potential liability issues
it is not a federally fda approved drug
it is federally illegal etc
but the experience has borne out that
there is little to no risk for licensure
actions against providers who are in
this market thank you for that
representative murphy has a question uh
thank you just a quick question um
so just from what you just said is the
requirement simply that the physician or
the provider have an active license uh
in the state to qualify a patient for
this program
right yes they must be licensed by uh
they must be licensed um
as a position um an aprn or a p a
physician assistant um they must have
prescriptive authority a dea regis
registration number for prescribing
control substances um there must be a
bona fide provider-patient relationship
with the patient um they must do uh you
know uh your your regular assessment see
the per the patient in person etc so
there's a number of requirements but
most of them align closely with um by
the provider's scope of practice what is
interesting though is that there are
provider types that do have prescriptive
authority in the state that are not on
the list of certifying providers for
cannabis um dentists podiatrists um are
not on the list um
uh we know that uh you know people's
teeth hurt you know
so it's it wouldn't be inappropriate to
consider that on that expansion of the
provider types that could be uh uh
certifying for the program and also um
naturopathic doctors have limited
prescriptive authority um and they're
not on the list and when you think about
cannabis as an herbal uh you know
treatment um it seems natural to you
know to consider naturopaths as well um
so that's an area of potential you know
legislation um to uh to look at
expanding the provider types allowed to
certify patients no cme requirements at
all no okay thank you
so which legislator are you who is are
you working with
we're uh this is a congress this is a
topic that has come up with the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board um so uh representative canark is
interested in considering this
legislation um and uh we'll be working
with him over the summer um whether or
not we don't know if it's department
requested or if it's tcmo be uh
requested uh but uh jerry cannor can we
uh
look at that okay since i already threw
you off here your
your
it's a great question thank you uh i um
how how is
the pricing of our therapeutic cannabis
program
um competing
with the uh the free market uh black
market
prices
are we
five times greater ten times greater i
have no idea what wheat goes for
so i don't know what black market prices
are um i do know that there is a gray
market um there is a gray market uh
cannabis um coming from medical cannabis
coming out of maine um the uh the main
model allows for
caregivers to register with the state
but they are not regulated by the state
so the costs are very low
so they the um essentially you could uh
in maine you register with the state as
a caregiver and you can grow cannabis in
your yard in your barn in your fields in
your basement and say that's medical
marijuana sell it to patients with cards
and there's no cost i mean the costs are
very low so the cost for uh there's no
cost for testing there's no regulations
regarding pesticide use etc so that
market is is significantly less by
almost a half of what the new hampshire
medical um cannabis is being sold for in
the dispensaries if you were to compare
the prices in new hampshire with the
prices in a regulated market say in
in massachusetts it's they are
comparable um uh
recreational in massachusetts is higher
due to the tax structure than
both the the prices of medical in both
massachusetts and new hampshire um
i will i will offer that so one of the
biggest policy changes that we've seen
in 20 in in this past
year
was the implementation of a portion of
senate bill 162
that was department requested
legislation
that in part allowed
new hampshire registered patients to
access all of the atcs in new hampshire
before that law passed a patient had to
go to one at a time they had to they had
to sign up with a particular atc there's
only three atc's um
in in the in the state so what that bill
did was allowed uh the the the patient
population to go to all seven of the
locations throughout the state
the the hope of that bill in addition to
increasing access to patients throughout
the state um was to create a bit of
friendly competition amongst the atc's
prices have come down a little bit
modestly it's you know
still most patients can't afford the
cannabis that they want to alleviate
their symptoms
but we have seen prices come down
because of that that competitive model
it's been interesting to see um one of
the atc's prime atc you know was the
first to lower their prices um in
anticipation of this uh of this bill
happening um and the other and the other
uh atc's followed suit
i'll come to you second to the follow-up
to that
is um
would it help the competitive natures of
the atc is if new hampshire law
allowed them to provide mobile delivery
allowing the atcs to deliver cannabis to
patients
the primary benefit of that would be
allowing people
who have access issues transportation
issues mobility issues people who can't
get to the dispensaries themselves or
have to pay a caregiver to drive them
that would be the the greatest advantage
of allowing home delivery
however that would be a premium
service and there
i would i would assume that there would
be an additional cost associated with a
delivery service um associated with uh
with that would you mind asking the atcs
if they might be interested in that
being able to do that
yes
i can tell you that the atc's are
interested in exploring that idea um i
will say that it is not the legislative
it is not the statute that prohibits uh
home delivery of cannabis by the atc
it is is um is the department's
administrative rules that prohibit that
um and and so it would it would be a
rule change
on our part to allow that um it is an
area that we uh that we've started
exploring especially due to um the uh
the pandemic um
um
we uh
and we haven't we haven't pursued it uh
since we we
achieved other models curbside um and uh
drive through windows et cetera uh like
like that but it's it's a it's a topic
for policy discussion certainly all
right thank you representative marshall
uh thank you i have a comment and a
question uh first of all uh i thank you
for your very complete uh report mr holt
it's a very excellent report uh i did
want to add uh to representative edwards
earlier question that the reluctance of
physicians dealt with prescribing not
certifying because prescribing uh for a
physician could easily be considered as
a violation of our licensure
my question has to do with warning
posters regarding cannabis use when
pregnant when lactating uh during
adolescence and accidental poisonings i
don't see any mention of the
implementation of that program in uh
your report and if you could comment on
that please yes thank you um and thank
you for the sponsoring that legislation
that uh whatever that does require the
atc's to provide
um
warning information in at the the
dispensary locations we've been working
with uh so that work is in progress um
we've been working with the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board to
develop the content of those uh those
informational bursars basically the the
risks themselves as you know that was a
provision in the law to
not establish the risks in statute
rather give the medical oversight board
the responsibility of establishing those
uh those risks um we are very close uh
we're working with uh with uh with chi
uh and we're very close to um uh and
hopefully hopefully this summer uh
releasing the um the brochures and the
posters relative to
um a pregnancy um we are not as far
along with the the adolescent risks
however we do have the the oversight
board um has completed their work in
terms of uh um the list of risks that
should be included in in those
information
follow-up question i i thank you for
that um as i'm sure you're aware we
added that requirement to the marijuana
legalization bill that passed the house
uh by floor amendment uh in recent
session and uh the intent was to have
this available such that if we do
legalize cannabis that we would be able
to use the same sorts of things
elsewhere in the state um can you
comment on that yeah i i appreciated
that amendment um
uh
it would be very it would be very
important to establish the same
or provide access
uh to the information uh for a
recreational market as as well so um
that was a you know when i think of the
legalization bills that we've seen in
the past um what i don't see in them is
uh public health concerns um addressed
uh proactively and uh and seeing that
language um added um to the bill was was
really was really great thank you thank
you
so so one of the things i've said to
people when they ask me why i support um
therapeutic cannabis and and why would
uh recreational cannabis
is that i believe the country has such a
severe fentanyl
problem
that a street
pot
is subject to being laced with fentanyl
which is
truly a public health hazard if people
smoke it and die
so i i think this is true is there
anything that you know that tell that
that you should tell me that i'm wrong
so i'll quit telling people i'm trying
to mitigate the uh the fentanyl risk
because i
i want there to be a source of of clean
uh
validated um marijuana
i don't have any specific information
related to cases in new hampshire or the
region of
fentanyl-raised cannabis um however i
can tell you that it makes absolute
sense it is true that a regulated
product is going to be safer than an
unregulated product
so absolutely
legal recreational adult use sales will
decrease the amount of black market not
necessarily gray market gray market is
it is legal to grow it is
illegal to give away it is not legal to
sell to your you know friends or
neighbors you know that's what we would
call gray market but a regulated product
is absolutely the the way to go um
whether or not there's you know cases of
fentanyl based cannabis in new hampshire
i can't i can't i can't speak to that
but you know when we think of it when
if you want me to continue if we think
about that you know the main model where
you know the the unregulated care giver
cannabis is
has no restrictions on pesticide use
isn't required to be tested
um
and we're sending and and people are
going across the border to to maine to
purchase because it is half the price
you know um for severely immune
compromised uh patients that's that's
not ideal you know so regulated products
are you know absolutely the
the way to go to to increase public
safety
so follow up on regulation and maybe
this is out of your domain but i think i
probably have an opinion i suspect you
know a lot
um back in the good old days when i was
18 and my family would go to colorado
they would have something called 3.2
beer which is a lower alcohol content
bigger than the regular beer that the
grownups got to drink and so this got me
to thinking because i keep hearing how
today's
pot
is has so much thc that
it's it's too much and that
there's evidence of psychotic reaction
to the thc
levels i'm just wondering if
if it might be a good idea for us if we
come back and we look at a legal
recreational pot again if there's a way
for us to stipulate
some lower thc content that would be
manufactured and marketed
as a less
powerful potent
uh option
i think that's a i think that's a great
idea um there's nothing just there's
nothing to stop uh the the legislature
from establishing that or the uh the
regulatory entity from establishing that
requirement um ultimately comes down to
the market and what people want to buy
um but if
the only cannabis flower products
available in a store have extremely high
thc
then there's no option for those uh
adults or those patients to purchase a
lower potency product um so you know so
sure
mandating a lower thc product as part of
the product offering is not an
unreasonable idea
do they effectively do that in the atcs
have gradations of thc content
they do
we still see a we still see a a tendency
towards
the highest thc product gets you know
you know is is is exciting for for
patients and it's and it's and it's
attractive um even though that is not
the product that's going to help them
with their condition you know the the
best um
but yeah to answer your question the
atcs all have a range of products with
different thc levels um they um that
they're growing you know they have cbd
rich strains as well that um that have
uh more cbd in them than thc so it
becomes a ratio product um and though
and those strains are um are
are fewer but they are increasing um we
inspected one of the facilities uh just
last week and and they started a
genetics program you know basically
cross-breeding their own um their own
strains and one of the goals for the uh
for this particular atc is to create
more cbd
strains low thc strains for those
patients that want them
uh so you got thrown way off track on
your um therapeutic cannabis breathing
do you have something specifically the
rest of the rest of it the rest of this
is boring it's just data um
you know uh
i would say that uh you know the atc
so i'll highlight a couple things you
know the atc's
collect effectiveness data
from patients
between nine and 32 percent depending on
the atc participate in that reporting of
effectiveness data um 88 to 97
you know of those respondents say it's
you know positive has positive feedback
with regard to effectiveness
satisfaction survey 99 of the patients
surveyed you know um say that the the
improved quality of life they'd
recommend the program to others who
qualify um you know we don't see that
kind of that that kind of success you
know in other programs you know the
people who are on this program um
they they need it they they appreciate
it they want to see it expand um they
want to see the cost come down that's
the number one concern of patients um
and and the other and the other policy
change that they would like to see
happen in new hampshire um
is
the allowance for home cultivation for
therapeutic cannabis patients it's you
know we hear that we hear that message
loud and clear all of the other issues
uh
that patients experience would lessen if
they were allowed to to cultivate their
uh their own um this past year um all of
the atc's came out in favor of home
cultivation for the first time um and so
the concern of like it would impact
their business model um
they considered it and they're like no
this is good for patients and so they
support it as well so
with uh yeah the program's running
smoothly cars going out on time within
statutory time frames um and they're you
know get get hardly any complaints
except for where can i find a doctor
why does it cost so much
when can i grow my own
are there questions from the community
because i think you still have the
prescription drug monitoring program
i do
okay
um
yeah this this may uh this may take
longer um it's possible um i will say
that uh
the
prescription drug monitoring program is
a is a new program for me personally um
and and so uh the the the thoroughness
in which i can answer questions about
the therapeutic cannabis program may not
be matched uh with with the pmp uh so
that said um
this prescription drug monitoring
program uh annual report uh required by
statute um and it contains again data
from fiscal year 2021 um so you know
closing period of june 30th 2021 again
this data is old as well we have one
slide that shows trends moving you know
into into this year um and i'll get to
that later um so it's been a transition
year for the pdmp as uh everyone knows
on july 1st um the pdmp was transferred
from the office of professional
licensure and certification to the
department of health and human services
through house bill 2.
um pdmp staff was were transferred over
um to dhhs as well
um
but the program administrator position
for the pdmp has been was vacant for
about a year um
so a significant amount of institutional
knowledge has been lost due to that
vacancy and due to the transfer
we did successfully hire a program
administrator um in april of this year
his name's sean jackson he's sitting in
the gallery uh behind you he may be
coming to you next year with the pdmp
report um so uh i just wanted to you
know call him out um so i'm gonna i'm
gonna focus my narrative on on program
updates since the program has been at
hhs even though the data report in front
of you is from
the previous fiscal year
other than the agency transfer the most
significant change to the pdmp this past
year was the passage of senate bill 45
from the 2021 session that bill
permitted the integration of pdmp data
into um
the new hampshire natural practitioner's
electronic health records um
so uh what does this mean well
integration allows pdmp data to become
part of the clinical workflow for
providers where it's most valuable
previous to this providers had to go to
a separate web portal login
run their patient query review their
prescription history
outside of their the clinical workflow
uh and this bill uh allowed for the the
integration um it makes
access to the pdmp data more efficient
more compliant with state law and
contributing to better clinical
the outcomes
what's the status of that integration
authorizing it is is very different than
having the vendors who sell ehrs uh
change your software to implement it
yeah absolutely so do you know what the
actual implementation status is uh yes i
can't tell you specific numbers of
entities that have adopted it already
but i can tell you that in january
january of this year we entered into a
new multi-year contract with our pdmp
vendor they're called bamboo health
formerly apparenthealth um and
subsequent to that contract that
contract contained support for this
integration module it's called pmp
gateway we have launched
this uh this module and there has been
uptake um in the in the provider
community for it all the the major
retail pharmacy chains um have adopted
it and a number of smaller providers as
you as you say the the
the larger health systems
dartmouth elliott concord they're going
to have to work with their ehr vendors
and do that transition um so that's
going to take some time
but we've we've met a number of times
with the new hampshire hospital
association they're well aware of this
uh this opportunity um and and and many
facilities are moving forward with that
so it's it's available um
the the other piece of that is that the
the state is funding the first two years
of this integration through the contract
um and so you know it is it is in every
health entity's best interest to get on
board as soon as possible um to have the
benefit of this uh this service um
before they potentially have to pay for
it we're gonna continue looking for
other uh funding sources um you know uh
before it expires to see if we can
continue funding it um but uh
but yes so it's uh it's it's out there
and available
um the contract is a number of other
enhancements i won't get into that i
know we're you know short on time i want
to highlight that the other significant
change to the pdmp this past year um was
also the result of house bill 2. um
senator roosevelt and i had a
conversation about this
yesterday um and many of you may know
this
house bill 2 changed the confidentiality
standard applicable to the release of
data from the pdmp
um pdmp has always been limited in what
in what kind of data it could share
and that only de-identified aggregate
data could be released uh what house
bill 2 did
was introduce a specific hipaa standard
um
which is specifically cited in statute
it's the it's the safe harbor standard
it reads the it reads all patient
specific protected health information
shall be de-identified in accordance
with section 164.514
b2 of the hipaa privacy rule
in part this means that all location
identifiers smaller than the entire
state must be removed including city and
including county
the only exception to this standard in
the in in hipaa rule is an allowance to
use the first three digits of a zip code
we call this zip three
but only if the area formed by that zip
three region has more than twenty
thousand people
you can you can see where i'm going
new hampshire it has one of 17 zip three
areas in the entire country with less
than 20 000 people
so ironically the effort in house bill 2
to protect the privacy of new hampshire
citizens by citing the safe harbor
standard actually decreases the privacy
protections afforded by the law for this
particular region of the state
to protect against this decrease in
privacy the report in front of you
presents data from this region combined
or integrated with uh with an adjacent
region i'd ask you to take a look at
page 4 of the report in front of you so
you can get a picture of what this means
so we created a we created a zip 3 map
which over which overlays the the zip
three regions onto the county regions
you'll see that you'll see that nothing
map you know nothing matches up
um
so what does this what does this mean uh
well the change breaks the continuity of
historical pdm pdp data that's been
released since the program began
and i would argue that you know county
data is the fundamental locational unit
of data used by hhs and other agencies
throughout the state
and for pdmp data to not be available by
county
means that the utility of pdmp data
statewide is diminished
so we at hhs would encourage the
legislature to take another look at this
change um to the confidentiality
standard and see perhaps if there's
other options here um allowing allowing
county level data to be released would
go some way to to fixing the immediate
need of um of releasing more consistent
data
senator roosevelt thank you we did have
a conversation
yesterday but i'd like to
um just state publicly that
what i said to mr holt was the
legislature's action to better protect
the privacy was intentional
it was not
a mistake by the legislature
so while we might be open to
allowing the identification down to
county level because it's more
protective
i think if the department
tries to risk
to loosen the privacy protections beyond
that
i think there will be pushback from the
legislature
thank you my guess having
worked with you
and i wanted to just say that
publicly rather than
between me and mr holt on the phone
we would we would be
thank you for that um we would be happy
with uh with with uh the change to
county only i mean that gets us that
gets us you know much much closer to
where we need to be
um so let me let me run really quickly
through some of the data in here um
how much time do you think you need
without panic
where you could just tell three minutes
oh okay great
i'll just give everyone in the audience
a heads up if you have something for the
uh oversight committee in about three or
four minutes you'll be invited
all right thank you um so
provider registration counts have
increased by 12
patient queries
providers querying the system
for a patient's prescription histories
have increased by five percent
um
i'd ask you to take a look at page eight
of the report this shows uh prescription
trends
um by drug type for a two year period
starting in july 2019
opioids filled prescription counts for
opioids have decreased by seven percent
filled prescription counts for
stimulants however have increased by 14
sedatives gone down by five
if you turn to page nine we've project
we've
uh this like i said earlier this data is
older um slide nine shows these trends
continue through quarter three of the
current fiscal year through march 2022
opioids continue their downward trend
down 13
stimulants continue their upward trend
up 22
sedatives down 6 percent
um the slides that follow break down
this data a little more
the decrease in opioids is consistent
across not only prescription counts but
also days supply and potency
the increase in stimulants is consistent
across prescription count day supply and
total milligrams prescribed
um and there are some location-based
slides in there as well for your review
but it's not particularly meaningful to
say that region zero three three three
experienced a percentage drop in opioid
prescription counts um
so there are at least three people on
this committee
that could respond to this better than i
could um the fact that our stimulant use
is going up
it would is obviously a red flag
what what's the potentiality of this
what are the downsides or the positive
sides and i'd like i'd like to hear
are we on a cusp of a new wave of crisis
i i can't answer that i can tell you
that we the division of public health
services in particular is very
interested in this data and we're
starting to look carefully at it and um
to explore what it might mean what it
might mean in the future what it might
mean for our for for kids being
prescribed um these uh these stimulants
at a young age and continuing that use
into into adulthood um
for hhs this is new data um and and it's
and it's
it's
it's very interesting
and we will be working with this uh
stimulate data in the in the coming year
so mr chair can i have some follow-up
well he's on the same line oh yeah
absolutely uh i i just was going to ask
mr williams to add to the 23 september
an opportunity for
the department to come back and talk
specifically to
the issues around the stimulant increase
but go ahead yes
as i'm sure most of us are aware mr
james potter the medical society spoke
on numerous occasions about the natural
natural history of opioid epidemics and
he has stated uh that typically
an opioid epidemic is followed by a
stimulant epidemic
and he has speculated on numerous
occasions that the next epidemic in new
new hampshire would be metamphetamine
i'm particularly concerned about the
stimulant increase and my question is
has the department discussed with the
medical society if further education is
needed regarding increased stimulant use
which you referred to in page five and
also in the prescribing data which you
cited and my second question
has to do with
the
whether legislation is
advisable regarding the need to query
the pdmp right now one has to query the
pdm people for prescribing an opioid but
there is no requirement to query the
pdmp before prescribing a stimulant and
that could easily be added in
legislation does the department think
that would be a good idea thank you
uh we have not had conversations with
the medical society on this topic yet
but again this is this is uh especially
with a a september
date to come back here and provide
updates we certainly will over the
summer
i can't say whether it's a good idea or
not to require um use we you certainly
could require on pdmp queries uh prior
to uh um admin uh
prescribing uh stimulant
i wanna look at some um have
conversations about what we think this
means um before that but there's uh
there's no reason why we can't have
those conversations while there's
legislation pending
so
so uh thank you for that represent marsh
so um given that there are multiple
entities that you would want to maybe
voice an opinion and have an integrated
solution from is the 23rd of september a
reasonable amount of time for you to
come back and give us a briefing on on
this trend and what we might want to do
to proactively engage it
september is certainly a time that we
could give you status on what we have
come up with
so far um i don't think you know summer
you know two months in the summer is
going to give us enough time to to
get give you what you want um but we're
happy to come back in september to let
you know where we're at
with it all right thank you
dr murphy uh thank you in i would just
echo the the concerns about the rise of
stimulant use
experientially using the opioids and
prescribing as we did
was uh oftentimes onerous and therefore
we knew that you know it made it
difficult to prescribe regularly
there was a time as you know when that
was the fifth you know vitasign pain and
we responded to that by prescribing
opioids since the pdmp has come into
effect that has gone down substantially
but without monitoring the stimulants
that has gone up not only because of the
increase in use in the youths in youth
but also that as an alternative but i
would just
echo the sentiment about maybe
legislation to help you know monitor
that because my experience is that
providers respond to data if you have
data to show them with use of a drug or
prescribing a drug they tend to respond
to it so i think it would be a great
idea
thank you
i would expect that
once the the gateway product the
integration product um is adopted more
widely within the state the ease of use
of the pdmp um will increase um it will
also the number of actual practitioners
use it utilizing um the pdmp will
increase currently about 55 of queries
are made by delegates not the
practitioners themselves um and so um
the the legislation from last year that
allow that integration is crucial um to
reducing the barrier uh for potential
legislation
that would increase the mandatory use of
the system
we did not specify a not later than date
and that legislation for the integration
though did we were and
if we did when is it and if we didn't
should we have i'm not sure i understand
not later then well uh it's one thing to
tell somebody that they have to do
something but then the next question
gets to be well when does it need to be
done the legislature did not tell them
tell providers that they have to do this
the legislature permitted it
permitted the pdmp
to enter into contracts and with uh to
integrate so there's no there's no
mandate for
um
healthcare entities to adopt this
integration module um
we're we're we're you know we're
um for the first two years and you know
that may be another consideration
if there's no funding two years from now
you know for this integration you know
will we see healthcare providers
especially smaller and smaller entities
you know um use it for a year and then
stop using it so that may be a
consideration as well if we're um if uh
for future legislation and funding
okay so you know david weeders
just talked to him about the budget very
well i know david okay
thank you
on a related
um issue with the pdmp the department
used to report
what percentage of
the
prescribers by category
were registered with the program and
using it
i think there are seven
licensed types where their licensees
can prescribe controlled substances
is the department still able to
tell us what percentage of veterinarians
are
registered and using it naturopaths
who actually can prescribe this stuff
and the other
the other
licensed categories can you do that yes
yeah the the we're still we'll start
we're still collecting that data we
didn't present it in this report but
we're but we have that i hope you will
include it in
next reports absolutely thank you thank
you
uh that's all i have
okay dr salloway
this is your last uh hhs committee are
you coming back in september
i'll be back
okay all right good it's always great to
have you here
um
all right um
this is last call
for anyone in the crowd we could call
this the unscheduled public comment time
are there are there any issues that
anyone in the
crowd would like to bring up
not seeing any
let's talk about our next meeting a
couple of times i've mentioned the 23rd
of september during the course of the
meeting
um this was suggested by mr williams mr
williams is there any specific reason
you pick the 23rd of september for the
next meeting
chairman edwards thank you very much for
the record john williams legislative
director for health and human services
and that date was based upon
communication with the um chair of the
committee represent pearson and he had
mentioned to me that he had intended and
provided a few items for the agenda for
friday september 23rd it doesn't
preclude he may want to elect having it
earlier however given that the house has
around mileage until the end of august
it makes sense that in all likelihood it
will be friday september 23rd
i i have no issue does anyone on the
committee have an issue with that
no
all right uh thank you so
so i would recommend that we just go
ahead and forward and plan on the 23rd
of september for the next meeting
um is i think we've completed our work
as a committee any last calls uh
representative murphy just a quick
question of representative salloway on
in i'm sorry i didn't get the
handout that you gave us on precision
medicine which i fully support and agree
with and would love to see develop
on the
task force i didn't see
physician representation on that is the
new hampshire medical society intended
to be a physician or provider like a
psychiatrist or a primary care provider
i believe there is an intent to include
the medical society
i would add parenthetically
representative that you would make a
superb member of that task force
if i'm back i'd be happy to join
please note that mr chairman i i
that's great i i
i'm thinking that you may want to do a
small update to this document to include
a
public health professor from unh whether
active or retired me and mr chairman yep
and and then whatever slot uh
representative murphy might fit in i
think your er trauma doctor or with ps
orthopedics bones oh okay just a human
carpenter great i got a problem with my
ankle i want to see you about
okay so with that
is there a motion to adjourn
so moved second and seconded
all those in favor say aye
opposed nay
there being no nays we are adjourned
thank you very much
um
thank you very much hey thank you
you